just when they can afford at least
Americans are suffering sticker shock at
the grocery store the meat the deli the
ham the cheese even the bread is costing
more now according to the US Labor
Department food prices rose 2.6 percent
in April the biggest monthly jump in 46
years prices for staples like meat and
eggs surged even more I'm a single
parent I have a mortgage I have a car
note so you kind of think like what's
priority right now do I pay my mortgage
or do grocery shopping with tens of
millions of Americans newly unemployed
more than at any time since the Great
Depression soaring prices mean long
lines at food banks and more Americans
than ever questioning where their next
meal will come from one in five families
is food insecure she says the number is
two in five for families with children
under 12 and higher for African American
and Hispanic families as meat plant
workers who've grown ill and died from
the global pandemic dozens of plants
shut down I walk around with over 1,700
people that ain't safe at all president
Trump ordered the plants to reopen with
new precautions in the said he plans to
change visa rules so that plants can
keep foreign workers in the US longer to
replace those who are sick or under
quarantine but panic buying and a supply
chain slowed by social distancing or
driving prices higher Chicago's old
meatpacking district is filled with
restaurants now the old slaughterhouses
and meat packing plants have moved to
rural areas but the meat is still traded
on the Chicago commodities exchange a
few blocks away where prices have been
steadily rising with no cure and no
vaccine in sight the rising arc of food
prices continues to mimic the growth of
the virus itself john Hendren al jazeera
Chicago